boris costello
asks is mathematics itself the domain of
all languages including of course the
natural
and biological language
well there's a sense in which
mathematics is the language of all
sciences
they all work within a mathematical
framework
but mathematics itself doesn't
tell you how an how an ant
navigates right if you want to study how
an
ant navigates you're going to use
mathematics
but from mathematics you can't deduce
how an ant
navigates just a way of these are the
tools we can use to describe whatever
there is
and it's the same with language uh if
you look at the
i mean i mentioned before that language
is based on a
computational procedure which generates
an
infinite number of structured
expressions
hierarchically structured expressions
which in fact can
thoughts or can be sent off to some
sensory motor system to be externalized
that's the core of language well when
you begin to describe that system of
course you're using mathematics
you're using at least elementary
recursive function theory
theory of computation none more when you
proceed
but the mathematics itself doesn't give
you the answers to the questions
any more than it does for a bee
navigating